Alice you're here tonight for ginger and
Rosa fantastic film how's it feel to be
here nominated the British Independent
Film Awards I'm so proud so thrilled
it's great to be here you've got loads
and loads of other movies coming up as
well you've got beautiful creatures
which of course everyone is so excited
about how excited were you and you've
got the core for that oh you know it was
sort of such a strange process because
for a long time I sort of flirted with
the idea of it but was quite cautious
and then suddenly as flirting happens I
suddenly when I really want this don't
dammit and then I got it I was thrilled
so excited are you prepared you think if
this goes as big as something like
Twilight because that could be quite
life-changing in a way given it I'm not
prepared I'm in denial actually I do
think you deal with it no clue hopefully
well now tell me a little bit about what
we can expect from the film well I would
say just don't make assumptions I was so
that's what I made before I read it and
after about it I always fell in love I
think it's such a charming charismatic
world and I think people will find that
it's such a magical story of course
isn't it now if you could have any kind
of power or magic power in real life
what would you be able to do what would
you like to do oh god you know that's
thus the most difficult question I've
spent 18 years trying to figure that one
out I can't so are you looking gorgeous
tonight and of course in ginger rows you
get to worse and fantastic out of this
world
in the sixties period are you a fan of
the vintage die yourself
oh I do I am I'm a real fan of it I mean
it started when as a teenager that's
what you can afford but now I'm just
comfortable and things with holes in our
and did you try and take away any of the
clothes from ginger row so that you
liked a particular I tried very hard but
they've been locked away somewhere out
of my reach what else can we look
forward to from you neck forearm small
independent film which is good to
mention at the Independent Film Awards
is going to Sundance called in fear
psychological thriller very happy with
it it's terrifying
enjoy
you